we are rounding off
our list of standard integrals okay now
you will recall
these results even if um in class you
haven't derived them yet and why they
are you have seen them okay and they are
there on your sheet
you'll remember as well why there isn't
a corresponding one for cos
inverse on the standard integral sheet
why is that
because it's yeah it's hidden here isn't
it it's just the negative
of this right so you can integrate this
and just as easily
get to negative cos inverse
you'll just have a different constant
virtue okay
all right that's all fine now today
we're going to address
uh the two last of the standard
integrals that are on there
unfortunately there's not any real nice
elegant simple way
that i can like i did with the um
inverse trig derivatives
to write them for you i'm just going to
do the tried and true method of if i
could differentiate
something
and get this result right generalizing
from what i'm doing here i can make an
integral statement of this
kinda i can say the integral of f dash
with respect to x should take me back to
my original offset by a constant
okay provided of course you can work out
what
this um original function is and then
choose it to
differentiate it then you can make this
statement okay
so we'll do this in a couple of steps
and then we'll fill out this so it's all
nice and neat okay so that's why i've
got this off on another side
let's consider
okay now here's the function i'm looking
at let's have a look at this guy
yeah it's a plus yeah
okay now this is really simple you don't
need to be extension two students
to know this okay i should prop sort of
brackets there it doesn't look like it's
gonna become anything special does it
but let's just walk through it anyway
one piece at a time
what do we start with one good
okay now hopefully you can see enough
here that i don't have to rewrite it
index four
what's the derivative of this guy going
to be it's chain rule isn't it
what should we start with inside or
outside look at the inside outside
i had inside first okay so the inside of
course is
2x excellent okay now what you've got on
the outside is some function to the
power of
a half a half okay so
i'm gonna multiply by the power and i'm
gonna
reduce the power by one yes
now being that this is a half when i
reduce it by one i get
negative a half right which means it's
still square root but it's on the
denominator okay so i'm getting this
okay so far so good yeah okay so i've
got one
plus that just becomes x doesn't it
bless you now again doesn't look like
there's anything particularly unusual
about this
i'm just going to put this all in a
common denominator though because then
you'll be able to see something
interesting okay because that's just 1
right it'll be the square root of x
squared plus a squared on
the square root of x squared plus a
squared right so i'm just going to get
this business
x squared plus a squared plus x
now the reason why this is interesting
is because it is so similar to the
function i started with
right this the numerator here
is exactly the same as this right
so therefore i'm going to take advantage
of this and keep going
over here and i want to consider what
happens when i take the log of this
function and differentiate that
okay so i differentiate log of
all of that stuff okay
okay now it's chain rule but we've
already worked out
f dash haven't we it's gonna be f dash
on f
f dash on f what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen because this
numerator here exactly matches
the numerator of f dash exactly matches
f it's just going to cancel out
completely in case you're it's the
afternoon so you know your brain's a bit
fuzzy let me write it out for you
here's f dash
all over this
there you go there's f dash and i'll
write it in the correct order just to
make the
canceling a little more obvious there's
f is that okay
so you get some grand cancelling
happening and all you're left with is
this
okay so now i'm going to come over here
this is my 3a result i'm getting to my
standard integral now okay
the derivative of this log function
awkward as
it seems
okay ends up being something quite nice
and simple
and it is very suspiciously close
to our inverse sine and inverse tan
functions
if you're like me when i got to this
point i actually got quite confused
because
they look so close to each other this
result this result and this result
they can be quite easily mixed up so be
careful okay
that's the derivative statement so of
course the um
converse integral statement just takes
this guy slaps him on the left hand side
with respect to x and that's going to be
my line function
offset by a constant okay
now um i mixed something up here sorry
not that it matters but it's easier to
see the next result if i put that in the
right order
i want you to have a look through where
i started from here all the way down
through to here
okay now tell me what significance does
this
a squared have a squared right
what's significance or what change does
it make to the derivative that i end up
getting
did i ever have to take into account the
value of a squared
i didn't really did i right every stage
when i did like the inside derivative
and so on i more or less ignored it
right it never became a coefficient of
anything really so therefore this
a squared i can actually sum it up for
anything i like that's a bit weird isn't
it
the reason why they put it like this is
because it draws the parallel between
one of these okay
so therefore this is the last of the
standard integrals hardly worth
being a different integral but i can
take this
and if i make an x squared minus a
squared
right so it is still another constant of
some kind which again is not going to
factor in if i did the whole process
again
with a minus sign it's going to be
log off and it'll be the same except
with a minus sign
x plus